what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and this is a big one we have to
discuss we get to see the official
proclamation of the victor in the sun
god luffy versus yonko kaido fight we
get to see the aftermath of the battle
in the citizens reaction to finding out
what happened we see what happened to
kaido and big mom and we even catch up
with zorro for a bit and i'm always
dying for more zorro so make sure to
stay tuned for this one chapter 1050
called honor chapters divisible by 50
are usually important i assume and this
one is no exception smash that like
button and in that way trigger the
youtube fireworks to celebrate juano's
liberation be a smashing pirate king
rather than a passing orochi make this
the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece reviews and
updates and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
we start off with kaido still falling
into the earth ever deeper we are told
we pretty much see what looks like him
going so deep that he's in magma now my
earth science peeps may be able to get
more specific in the chat we are shown a
diagram of how he and big mom pretty
much made it to the same place with
their different holes definitely feels
cartoonish but after luffy's awakening
we can't be surprised by cartoonish i
don't even assume for a second this
could kill the yonkos since this is one
piece and these are yonko but at least
it should add to their injuries
hopefully making sure that they don't
get up anytime soon in the skies above
wano luffy is still falling having
passed out from exhaustion as well
seemingly yamato is chasing after him
probably to catch him and then it
happens as i guessed what happened this
chapter we are told that the declared
victor of the rooftop battle has been
revised so this appears to be the
narrator talking so we always have to
pay special attention to this while
kaido is falling ever deeper in the
earth luffy is being delicately handled
by yamato yamato looks at the exhausted
luffy and smiles even laughing a bit
it's actually a really beautiful smile
and very nice moment um was also shown
exhausted after pulling through and
saving the island from crashing the
people in the capital are still
celebrating and launching lanterns into
the air with their wishes meanwhile
yamato says to luffy and momo you guys
really are something i can't believe it
and i feel like that's luffy at this
point he will do stuff that people can't
believe can be done that's part of what
it means to be the freest and definitely
his ridiculous devil fruit power goes a
long way in helping him achieve those
seemingly impossible things we jump to
the capital where the festival has
started to die down we see toko
screaming up up and away and tenguyama
hitetsu is there too toko in a flashback
mentions that she heard someone say that
her dad knew they would kill him because
he used to be a really big deal but he
decided to let himself get caught anyway
so that he could give his life in order
to give this country one last chance as
hitetsu points out if not for shimotsuki
yasui the adoptive father of toko the
embers of hope they were entrusted with
would have been snuffed out in an
instant he sacrificed himself for the
future an epic character and an epic
legacy to leave behind we get an
absolutely beautiful flashback where we
see yasu freaking out that toko ate the
fruit that made her laugh uncontrollably
so then he too ate it saying well then
why don't i have a bite so she wouldn't
have to go through it alone i don't know
why exactly but that hit me so
hard in the feels i love how without
even a second thought he decided to put
himself in the same boat to make it
easier for her it sort of reminds me of
how might guy was willing to bet his own
life on rock lee recovering that's what
makes people real parent figures more
than just share dna then after that
beautiful moment we go back to present
toko and hitetsu hitetsu says yasu hoped
that one day toko would be able to live
happily toku replies so it was for me
then let me change my message hitsu
notices the new message and cries saying
for a samurai there is no greater honor
and he just did it he said the title of
the chapter in the chapter and it could
not be more impactful she crossed out i
want to see you daddy and wrote thank
you daddy man it just makes you wanna
cry my eyes totally watered so don't
feel bad if yours did too it's totally
manly it's all good we see the night sky
lit up the light shining on toko's
bright and hopeful face we see hitetsu
smiling again beautiful moment after
beautiful moment in this chapter
nekomamushi sees the lights and remarks
that the sight takes him back he tells
everyone on what was onigashima that
there is no doubt about it now luffy
drilled kaido straight down into the
ground furthermore he lets them know
momo used his dragon form to keep
onigima from crashing nekomamushi says
it's been 20 years since this feud over
odin's regret began and now it's finally
over what is clearly continuing to wrap
this up emphasizing that it's over again
and again people exclaim we've won we
beat two emperors of the sea what a hype
statement that is like let's just
process it for a second we beat two
emperors of the sea
to yonko one half of the yonko insane we
see shots of characters including kid
and killer lion beppo which is a funny
one and even apu who i just hate i hate
abu man but at least we get to see him
super shocked that straw hat took down
kaido because he was all like bro nobody
could take down kaido bro we see
characters celebrating including nami i
love how marco is just chilling there
leaning back and smiling man he looks so
cool right there we see usopp and
frankie bringing the wounded including
zoro i'm so excited to see what the
explanation for that god of the
underworld figure that appeared before
zoro will be and like i said before it
would be hype if it was enma's awakening
i outlined that zoro already has a devil
fruit theory in a video link in the
description if you haven't seen it but
for now things really seem to be
wrapping up here momo communicates with
zunisha saying he's given a lot of
thought and he's decided not to open
wanos borders yet a very interesting
choice maybe he's saving it for after
luffy fulfills his full destiny and for
the end of one piece we shall see and
zunisha says very well i shall follow
your lead i trust your judgment this
could also open the door for wano and
some of the threads brought up here to
be answered later on since we are
clearly not done with wano yet even if
the ark finishes and the straw hats
leave wano temporarily then momo feels
an earthquake beast pirates are firing
cannons saying there's no way kaido lost
and they won't give up they have pride
in the fact that they are yonko crew
after all which makes sense yamato is
the one to step in telling them that
their lives were spared thanks to momo
and if they keep fighting yamato will
personally grind them to dust very cool
yamato
very cool then the earthquake keeps
being felt we see kaido and big mom's
silhouettes in an underground magma pool
before an underwater volcano erupts the
narrator says decisive battle in
disguise of wano victor straw had luffy
so it's about as officially over as it
can get at least in one chapter yes oda
did revise kaido's victory so it's
theoretically possible he could revise
it again but it just wouldn't feel right
going back and forth like that all the
time the proclamations would begin to
lose all meaning we see luffy sleeping
and his face smiling there's the face of
a dude who has definitely earned his
rest then the people of wano react to
the explosion momo appears and tells
them that he's not kaido and the
eruption was the final send-off for the
supreme commander of the beast pirates
momo should definitely be able to sense
if kaido is no longer a threat right now
and according to him he's clearly not
momo goes to transform into human and
the silhouettes of our samurai begin to
appear behind the smoke you know this
will be one of those very epic moments
with epic music when animated they see
komurasaki aka hiri who they thought was
dead so they call her a ghost pretty
much then denjiro appears telling them
that it's a long story but first let him
present the new shogunabuano so yeah
it's hard to argue that the raid will
fail right now still it's not a nice bow
on top ending either since momo has yet
to decide to open wano next chapter we
are likely going to see momo's human
form which i'm psyched to see and you
know he'll look like odin continuing the
ghost theme that was brought up when
they called hillary a ghost let me know
your thoughts on all this will anyone
else show up like blackbeard shanks the
world government and so on will
blackbeard find kaido's defenseless body
and do a little mythical zone fruit
consumption wano isn't over yet and even
if this is an arc epilogue that we're in
already there's so much to look forward
to seeing i'm glad some characters are
fine like usopp frankie marco jimbei and
more so if anyone does show up at least
it's not like every straw hat is
defenseless right now smash that like
button if you enjoyed this review and to
celebrate juano's liberation with that
beautiful youtube firework effect very
fitting youtube very fitting i'm glad
that they want to celebrate juano's
liberation right now be a smashing power
king rather than passing a rochi make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece reviews and
updates and as you wait for zorro to
recover and explain what's going on with
the god of the underworld that he saw
check out this new video on the screen
right now where i explore zoro's
post-wano bounty and how he'll rise to
the status of the new fifth emperor see
you there